[Musique]
des centaines de familles ne peuvent
toujours pas faire leur deuil des
libanais qui attendent des réponses de
la justice sur les circonstances de
l'explosion du 4 août dernier des heures
des jours des semaines interminables
face à une enquête qui piétine
l'enquète a jusqu'à présent été
complètement scandaleuse
il n'y a pas de transparence sur le lieu
de l'enquète une enquête criblé de
violation de la procédure régulière elle
a été entachée d'ingérence politique et
aucun responsable de haut niveau n'a été
tenu pour responsable au lieu de cela
vous avez 25 fonctionnaires des douanes
et de la sécurité portuaire qui
croupissent en prison tandis que les
dirigeants politiques se promènent
librement échappe à toute responsabilité
ou obligation de rendre compte des
investigations pour expliquer comment
près de 3000 tonnes de nitrate
d'ammonium ont pu être entreposés dans
le port de beyrouth pendant des années
et en toute connaissance des risques
potentiels par les autorités une enquête
paralysé par des rivalités politiques
six mois après l'explosion il est
inacceptable que le liban n'est toujours
pas de gouvernement pour répondre à la
crise sanitaire et social et engagé les
réformes structurelles indispensables au
redressement et à la stabilité du pays à
tous les responsables de ce pays je
voudrais vous redire que votre
responsabilité individuelle et
collective est majeur il y ait le
courage d'agir et la france vous aidera
paris qui a tâté une nouvelle fois du
poing sur la table ce jeudi face à des
engagements restée lettre morte
le chef de la diplomatie française et
son homologue américain ont appelé le
liban à se doter sans plus tarder d'un
gouvernement condition sinequanone d'un
soutien à long terme de la communauté
internationale il y a un besoin urgent
et vital que les responsables libanais
met enfin en oeuvre leurs engagements de
former un gouvernement crédible et
efficace et de travailler à la
réalisation des réformes nécessaires
conformément aux aspirations du peuple
libanais ces actions concrètes restent
absolument nécessaire pour que la france
les états unis et leurs partenaires
régionaux et internationaux s'engagent à
apporter un soutien supplémentaire
structurelles et de long terme au liban
emmanuel macron s'est rendu à deux
reprises à beyrouth depuis l'explosion
du 4 août dernier le président français
a récemment annoncé son intention d'y
retourner pour fustigé l'inaction des
dirigeants libanais après la
déflagration le gouvernement a
démissionné mais il gère encore les
affaires courantes saad hariri désigné
premier ministre fin octobre n'a
toujours pas formé son équipe des
marchandages politiques qui perdure
alors que la ville de beyrouth se
reconstruit lentement et que la
population sombre dans la misère à
l'heure actuelle un libanais sur deux
vit désormais sous le seuil de pauvreté
selon les nations unies soit 22% de plus
en seulement trois ans